coming up next week Greece and to
terrorism and a mini plenary welcome to
the agenda for weeks it's been the most
talked-about subject well what exactly
new legislation on passenger name record
will or won't do we'll finally know when
the draw proposal is officially unveiled
it all kicks off on thursday when a new
report will be presented by its author
last time around it failed to pass go
will it be green lighted it's seen as a
tool to fight the latest wave of
terrorist attacks but does it do enough
to maintain privacy and data protection
french talks between Greece and his
creditors Kennedy will be salvaged Oh is
Greece looking at a closer to amusing
exit the European Central Bank has done
Greece a lifeline for giving it over
three billion in liquidity for banks so
what will the president of the Eurogroup
drone days or bloom have to say when he
comes to the Parliament on trans things
Greece will continue to be the talk of
the town the day after as a mini plenary
hits Brussels on Wednesday look out for
a debrief of the EU heads of state
meeting held on for every 12th also at
the Parliament the President of the
European Central Bank Mario Draghi he'll
be there for the unveiling of ECB's 2013
annual report will he make any
statements on Greece intense shelling by
pro-russian rebels saw a hasty retreat
by Ukrainian forces we did a survey on
Wednesday so where does the peace
process go from here on Tuesday the
chairperson of Ukrainian rada comes the
Foreign Affairs Committee the meeting
that comes on the back of the chair the
Russian duma's visit just as both
plenary in the week just passed and
finally the environment committee will
vote in reform of the emissions trading
system on Tuesday plans include
automatic back loading or delay of
emission allowance to drive up the price
of carbon and get a better balance
between supply and demand but when all
of that will come into play is also
subject for disputes and that's all we
have the gender take care and enjoy the
week
you